stavo raccontando ad essi la storia di
citata è una bellissima storia un
bellissimo mio è un modo di raccontare
la verità e ai bambini piace tanto
la manor board io ho un grande rispetto
per la vostra cultura è la vostra
religione
e so tutto dell'invasione del tibet e
delle tragedie che sono successe
però io non credo nella reincarnazione
né ci crede mia moglie perché dovreste
nel tibet
noi consideriamo la mente e il corpo
come il contenuto e il contenitore
ora la tazza non è più una tazza ma che
cos'è il tè e ancora the
esatto
nella tazza sul tavolo o sul pavimento
si trasferisce da un contenitore a un
altro ma è ancora te
così la mente dopo la morte
anch'essa da un corpo si trasferisce a
un altro ma è ancora mente
perfino nel panno
rimanete lo stesso te non per me grazie
allora intanto per parlare del futuro e
per pensare al nostro futuro
focalizzare un attimo l'attenzione sul
fatto che l'unico dato certo che abbiamo
è che non sappiamo quando né come
un giorno dovremmo lasciare il nostro
corpo chiarisce molto bene alcune idee
innanzitutto ci consente di ri
posizionare le nostre priorità
e anche in questo atto di
dare una nuova un nuovo ordine di
dare realmente il giusto valore alle
cose che per noi con importanti
la seconda cosa che ci consente di fare
è di
capire esattamente che cosa ci rende
unici
unici non significa insostituibile ma
significa
capire esattamente
come noi vogliamo costruire il nostro
pezzettino di mondo in questo pezzettino
di mondo ci sono poi anche le cose che
vogliamo lasciare ai nostri figli
alle persone che amiamo che vogliamo
banalmente lasciare a chiunque
segua dopo di noi
il futuro è uno stato d'animo
ed è uno stato d'animo su cui è bene che
incominciamo a capire come meglio
gestire le nostre risorse e gli stati
d'animo vanno allenati e vanno tenuti
vivi
sono quelli che gli stati d'animo sono
quelle emozioni che ci legano ai fatti
che accadono nella vita ognuno di voi sa
perfettamente che di fronte a uno stesso
fatto può avere reazioni diverse da
quelle che hanno le altre persone ed è
questa capacità di interpretare un fatto
e di portarlo dentro di noi con un
nostro preciso significato che cambia la
qualità della nostra vita
la qualità della nostra vita è
costituita da gioie dolori
le cose più importanti sono
assolutamente invisibili e quindi a
volte
riuscire a guardare quello che abbiamo
dentro da un punto di vista diverso ci
aiuta tantissimo a costruire il nostro
pezzo di mondo esattamente come come lo
vogliamo
ieri qualcuno mi chiedeva come sono
rivolta negli anni a fare quello che
faccio in
in questi incontri in questi
affiancamenti e accompagnamenti che io
o con le persone mi è venuto in mente
che la prima volta che io ho pensato di
lavorare sul cambiamento e mi è accaduto
quando ero molto
giovane avevo circa 13 anni
erano gli inizi era fine anni fine anni
settanta e
poi portata in russia mosca dove dovevo
seguire un corso di russo e una mattina
mi dissero che mi avrebbero portato
insieme alle altre compagne a visitare
il museo dell'armata rossa ora a fine
anni 70 la russia era molto diversa da
come oggi e quindi quando si entrava nel
paese si restava senza documenti e si
riceveva un piccolo pezzo di carta su
cui scrivevano il nome un numero e quel
numero serviva a identificarti dentro al
tuo gruppo di pari gli stranieri non
avevano contatti con la popolazione
russa
eravamo assolutamente separati
identificati in maniera molto chiara e
potevamo muoverci soltanto accompagnati
dalla nostra guida e quella mattina io
non so esattamente per quale motivo ma
essendo che a 13 anni ero
incredibilmente ancora un po più bassa
di quanto sono oggi riuscì
a sgattaiolare
nel contingente russo c'erano file
separate separate per nazionalità e la
fila dei tedeschi degli inglesi degli
italiani dai francesi
a un certo punto
combaciava con la fila dei russi e io in
fila e lì dentro e feci la mia visita al
museo dell'armata russa
separatamente ovviamente dalle mie
compagne di diversa nazionalità e quando
uscì
trovai le mie compagne intanto che mi
aspettavano perché la mia visita era
durato 45 minuti in più della loro
erano assolutamente annoiate e dal fatto
che avevano passato 1 a sentirsi
raccontare a vedere le uniformi che
andavano dalla guerra dal 1917 al 1922 e
trovarono che quella visita fu veramente
molto noiosa io invece uscire
assolutamente
sorpresa perché vivi in quelle stanze un
racconto molto particolare della storia
russa
che era il periodo della guerra fra il
1939 e il 1945 in cui mi raccontarono
quanto era importante
l'opera che i russi fecero in quegli
anni quanto
devastarono la germania quanto la
germania fosse stata
dura e crudele vidi un sacco di
documentari che le mie compagne e non
videro mai
e sulle quali però ci confrontammo
quando gli usci e in quella esperienza
io ricordo che ho imparato tre cose una
è che dello stesso tema devi almeno
leggere un 56 libri che provengono da
diverse culture
perché un'unica visione dello stesso
tema è assolutamente parziale a noi ce
l'avevano raccontata a quella parte di
storia a scuola ma ce l'avevano
raccontata in una maniera assolutamente
diversa la seconda cosa che imparai è
che ci sono degli insegnanti e che a
volte ciò futuri cevi come insegnamento
è qualcosa di diverso da quello che ti
può dare un maestro perché
l'insegnamento a volte parziale e quindi
bisogna saper riconoscere i maestri
nella vita che sono un po diversi dagli
insegnanti e solitamente i maestri
ti danno una visione molto più rotonda e
la terza cosa che imparai e che ogni
ideologia e la migliore per se stessa e
quindi bisogna cercare di stare il più
possibile svegli dentro le ideologie
nelle quali cresciamo perché è
importante
capire che tutto ciò che ideologico e
parziale manipolativo e non ci consente
a volte di venire a contatto con ciò che
è realmente la nostra essenza
questo perché lo racconto perché quando
davvero volete fare un percorso di
cambiamento e incominciare a capire come
costruire il vostro futuro
un po di sguardo al passato lo dovete
dare e dovete soprattutto liberarvi da
ciò che ritenete essere dei ganci che vi
tengono legati a rancori o rimpianti tra
ancora ho rimpianti non vi consentono di
mettere l'energia davanti quindi
guardandovi dietro
la riflessione da fare come includere
tutto ciò che avete vissuto è una cosa
interessante è che negli ultimi anni la
ricerca neuroscientifica ci ha dato un
sacco di elementi
per capire come mai alcune volte
facciamo fatica a lasciare al passato
uno di questi è che il dolore la
scomodità attivano delle parti del
cervello che solitamente non usiamo
quindi soltanto quando riusciamo a stare
realmente dentro al dolore e alla nostra
scomodità riusciamo a creare nuovi
comportamenti e nuovi modi di andare
avanti questa è una cosa che non
facciamo volentieri e quindi di solito
lasciamo quelle parti del cervello
spente accenderle
è una buona risorsa
la seconda cosa è che per guardare
avanti bisogna essere molto consapevoli
di dove stiamo
perché per andare a roma e importante
sapere se stiamo partendo da napoli o da
milano altrimenti a roma magari ci
arriviamo ma con dei giri e con delle
dispersioni di energia e con
fatic e assolutamente inutili quindi
sapere da dove stati partendo è
assolutamente fondamentale
per sapere questo significa che bisogna
stare un po fermi
fermi è un'attività che facciamo
raramente nei nostri giorni
siamo molto abituati a correre a
risolvere problemi
siamo spesso abituati a dare per
scontato una serie di cose stare fermi
non è proprio una cosa che ci viene
naturale
e molto importante
e l'altra cosa per costruire un buon
stato d'animo che ci consente di
guardare al futuro è
sapere che da soli non si va da nessuna
parte e che quindi le cose più
importanti che noi possiamo fare sono
costruire insieme agli altri essendo
consapevoli che tutti noi siamo
interconnessi e quindi la visione
collettiva è una visione che
implicitamente
contiene una visione etica io so che se
faccio uno sgarbo a questa parte della
sala prima o poi mi torna se sono
fortunata mi torna direttamente se sono
sfortunata attorno ai miei figli e
quindi bisogna stare molto attenti a
come facciamo circolare le nostre scelte
essere capaci di avere un equilibrio fra
ciò che diamo è ciò che riceviamo è un
altro elemento importante per rendere le
nostre relazioni sostenibili
non esistono relazioni adulte
non esistono relazioni adulte nelle
quali una persona solo da e non riceve o
solo
riceve e nulla da ci possono essere
delle relazioni nelle quali c'è un forte
disequilibrio ma non durano molto e se
durano non sono
generative di benessere per chi è
coinvolto in queste relazioni
quindi fate molta attenzione al fatto
che dare è importante ma anche sapersi
apri aprire per ricevere ciò che gli
altri ci vogliono dare è un elemento di
grandissima forza che ci consente di
essere solidi nella crescita del nostro
contesto della nostra rete e anche della
crescita del nostro futuro
io vorrei
chiudere con due parole sull'importanza
della riconciliazione perché una delle
cose che rende più grande il nostro
futuro rispetto al nostro passato e il
futuro se è davvero un futuro
positivo è un futuro molto più ricco e
grande di ciò che noi abbiamo già
vissuto e la capacità di includere
e di riconciliarci con tutto ciò che in
qualche modo abbiamo cercato di
escludere dalla nostra vita l'importante
è riuscire a
accettare ciò che è diverso da noi
abbandonare il giudizio è la cosa che vi
rilassa di più se vi permettete di non
avere opinioni e giudizi
sarete sicuramente più rilassati
nell'affrontare le scelte della vostra
vita e in particolar modo
vi volevo dare un
ultimo minuto sull'importanza della
riconciliazione anche quando è difficile
guardare negli occhi l'altra persona
e con questo volevo augurarvi un felice
è ampissimo ricco futuro